En este vídeo, vamos a hablar de Cataluña.
Durante estos meses, nos habéis mandado más
de 100.000 mensajes pidiéndonos que hiciéramos
un vídeo sobre Cataluña.
Y no es que nos quisiéramos mojarnos. El
problema es que no sabíamos qué podíamos
contaros que no estuvieran contando ya los
medios tradicionales… ¡Hasta ahora!
El vídeo de hoy va a ser MUY especial. Tras
muchos meses, os hemos traído al mayor experto
en autodeterminación del mundo ¿De quién
estoy hablando? Ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
Os voy a hacer una pregunta… ¿Quién ha
definido las fronteras del país en el que
vivís? Por ejemplo, supongamos que veis este
vídeo desde España ¿Quién ha decido que
IRÚN forme parte de España y no de Francia?
¿Por qué los países tienen la forma que
tienen y no otra distinta?
No se trata de ninguna pregunta estúpida. Estar a un lado
u otro de una frontera puede cambiarte radicalmente
la vida. Si no, que se lo pregunten a los
que viven en la parte Norte de la península
Coreana. En realidad, las fronteras son el
problema más complicado que existe en política.
Y por eso, cada vez que una región se quiere
separar del país al que pertenece, surgen
tantísimas polémicas. Os lo hemos dicho
muchas veces en VisualPolitik, el caso de
Cataluña no es único en el mundo.
En realidad, casi todos los países tienen alguna región
que quiere separarse. Sin embargo, ninguno
tiene un mecanismo legal para responder ante
esto.
En otras palabras, podemos discutirlo todo:
distintos modelos económicos, ideologías
o valores morales… pero nadie puede poner
en duda las fronteras del país en el que
vive.
Y ya sé lo que estaréis pensando muchos
¿Por qué no se permite que los ciudadanos
voten en un referendum? Por ejemplo, en el
caso de Cataluña ¿Por qué no permitimos
que los ciudadanos catalanes acudan a las
urnas para decidir sobre su futuro? En principio,
suena bastante justo ¿verdad? Pero imaginad
este escenario. Imaginad qué pasaría si
el 60% de los catalanes elije separarse de
España. Sin embargo, el 60% de los barceloneses
quiere quedarse ¿Qué haríamos en este caso?
Si Cataluña se independizara, entonces la
mayoría de los barceloneses estarían viviendo
en un estado nuevo en el que no se sienten
identificados ¿Qué derecho tienen el resto
de los catalanes para imponer sus condiciones
a los barceloneses?
Como veis es algo mucho más complicado de
lo que parece. Y eso explica que, a lo largo
de la historia, la independencia haya generado
tantísimas guerras. Si no me creéis, sólo
mirad la historia de los Balcanes. Es más,
para que os hagáis una idea, sólo hay
UN PAÍS en el mundo que tiene reconocido el
derecho de autodeterminación en su constitución.
¡Bienvenidos a Liechtenstein!
Liechtenstein tiene poco más de 36.000 habitantes,
repartidos en 11 municipios. Pues bien, cualquiera
de esos municipios tiene el derecho a convocar
un referendum de autodeterminación y convertirse
en un país independiente.
Y os preguntaréis ¿Pero cómo funciona este
sistema? ¿Cómo es posible que un país tan
pequeño, que apenas tiene 35.000 habitantes,
pueda atomizarse en países aún más pequeños?
Para responder a esta pregunta, nos hemos
ido a hablar con su serenísima alteza, el
Príncipe Hans Adam II.
Hice unas prácticas en el Banco exterior
de España, en el País Vasco, en San Sebastián…
en los años 60. Fue una experiencia muy interesante
para mí.
Y ahí descubrí que había un movimiento
que pedía más autonomía para la región,
incluso la independencia. Así es como empecé
a pensar en la autodeterminación ¿Cómo
lo haces para que los estados no se rompan?
En 1992, el derecho a la autodeterminación
entró a formar parte de la Constitución
de Liechtenstein. Es decir, que cualquiera
de sus municipios podría separarse en cualquier
momento. Para que os hagáis una idea, este
pueblo que véis aquí es la villa de RUGELL,
uno de los 11 municipios que componen Liechtenstein.
Tienen menos de 2000 habitantes, es decir,
que cualquier bloque de viviendas en una gran
ciudad tendría más población.
Sin enmabargo, en cualquier momento, los ciudadanos de Rugell podrían convocar un referendum y convertirse
en un país independiente.
“Sería impensable pero sería posible si
los ciudadanos presentaran una iniciativa.
Si ganaran la votación, nos separaríamos.
Pero, bajo mi punto de vista, ahora mismo
no pasaría”
Y ahora os preguntaréis… si basta con 1500
firmas para convocar un referendum y cambiar
la constitución de todo el país ¿Cómo
es posible que se mantengan estables?
¿Por qué no se celebran referéndums de autodeterminación todos los días?
Una forma de responder a
esta pregunta sería porque Liechtenstein
es, junto a Qatar, el país más rico del
mundo ¿Quién querría separarse de sus vecinos
cuando tiene un salario medio que supera los
5000 dólares al mes? Pero, como os podéis
imaginar, esta no es la única razón.
La ventaja competitiva que tenemos es que
el Gobierno (el príncipe y el parlamento)
están más cerca de los problemas… y normalmente
más cerca de las soluciones. Normalmente,
sobretodo en los estados muy centralizados,
el político o el monarca, o el primer ministro…
necesitan muchísimo tiempo hasta que descubren
que hay un problema. Pero al final los problemas
aparecen y dices ¡Oh! ¡No me había dado
cuenta! Pero a nivel local, o regional, es
los problemas se resuelven mucho antes.
Lo habéis adivinado, Liechtenstein es el
país que más lejos ha llevado el principio
de la descentralización. Por ejemplo, en
un país como Suiza, los cantones, es decir
las regiones que componen el país, son las
entidades que toman casi todas las decisiones
políticas. En Liechtenstein van un paso más.
La institución política más importante
es el Ayuntamiento.
En algunos pueblos pueden decir que ya tienen
suficiente industria manufacturera o suficientes
extranjeros…
Para que os hagáis una idea, incluso la política
de inmigración está descentralizada. Por
ejemplo, vamos a imaginar que queréis conseguir
la ciudadanía Liechtensteniana y vivís en
Rugell.
Pues bien, los vecinos de este pueblo
convocarían un referendum en el que decidirían
si os aceptan o no. Y por supuesto, esto también
afecta a los impuestos. En Liechtenstein,
el impuesto sobre la renta tiene dos tramos.
Uno nacional, que igual en todo el país,
y otro, que es el más importante, que depende
del municipio. Para que os hagáis una idea,
vamos a suponer que, tenemos un sueldo de
100.000 francos al año, que serían el equivalente
a unos 85.000 euros. Si, ya sé es un sueldo
muy alto pero en Liechtenstein es bastante
común. Pues bien, de esos 85.000 euros, tendríamos
que pagar un 5% al gobierno central y después
pagaríamos el impuesto local.
Por ejemplo,
si vivimos en Ruggell, pagaríamos un 8,75%.
Es decir, que el total de nuestro impuesto
de la renta sería del 13,75%. Pero si en
lugar de vivir en Ruggell, vivimos en la capital,
es decir, en VADUZ, entonces pagaríamos algo
menos. En este caso, sería un 12,5%. Parece
poco, pero hablamos de casi una décima parte de
diferencia ¿Y por qué ocurre esto? Pues
en el ayuntamiento de Vaduz han decidido que
quieren cobrar menos impuestos. Y la Constitución
de Liechtenstein les da un enorme margen para
que fijen los impuestos a su antojo.
Y como os podéis imaginar, esta descentralización
a todos los niveles, le da un montón de autonomía
a los municipios. En otras palabras, que tienen
suficiente libertad como para que no necesiten
llegar a separarse del país.
Cuando presenté esta idea a Naciones Unidas
por primera vez, intenté llegar a un acuerdo
en la autodeterminación. El derecho a la
autodeterminación está en la Carta de las
Naciones Unidas pero nadie lo ha desarrollado.
La idea, en ese momento, era no poner independencia
total pero descentralización. Eso permitiría
que los países sigan juntos pero que sean
más democráticos. Este era el objetivo.
Pero ya sé lo que estáis pensando ahora.
Que sí, todo esto funciona muy bien en Liechtenstein
porque es un microestado. Con menos de 40,000
habitantes, es fácil que las cosas funcionen
pero… ¿Realmente podríamos aplicar este
sistema a países más grandes?
No creo que haya que ir tan lejos como el
Liechtenstein donde cualquier pueblo tiene
derecho a marcharse con una votación… Creo
que no puede resolverse a ese nivel. Pero
creo que se puede resolver a nivel local,
con autonomía. Creo que el problema, con
el 90% de la gente, se resolvería con más
autonomía.
Pero sin duda alguna, la pregunta, la auténtica
pregunta que os estáis haciendo todos en
este momento es… ¿Realmente podría aplicarse
este sistema político en la situación específica
de Cataluña y el resto de España? ¡Ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver!
CATALUÑA IS NOT LIECHTENSTEIN
Para los que nos veáis desde Latinoamérica,
os tengo que explicar que España está dividido
en 17 comunidades autónomas, con sus distintos
parlamentos y sus distintos gobiernos. Cataluña,
al menos por ahora, es una comunidad autónoma
más.
Y tienen sus propias leyes, distintas a las
de otras regiones. Por ejemplo, en Cataluña,
las corridas de toros están prohibidas mientras
que en otras comunidades no sólo son legales
sino que incluso están apoyadas por la administración.
Todo esto lleva a que muchos piensen que España
es un país muy descentralizado. Tal vez no
tanto como Liechtenstein pero similar a Alemania
o Estados Unidos.
Pero ¿De verdad está tan descentralizado?
Vamos a lo que realmente importa: el dinero.
Y volvemos al ejemplo del impuesto de la renta.
En España, al igual que en Liechtenstein,
el impuesto de la renta se divide en dos tramos:
uno nacional y otro autonómico.
Fijaos bien en la gráfica. Vamos a suponer
que ganamos 20.000 euros al año y vivimos
en la comunidad de Madrid. En este caso, pagaríamos
alrededor del 21% de Impuesto sobre la Renta.
10 puntos y medio corresponderían al tramo
nacional. Y los otros 10 puntos y medio restantes
serían el tramo autonómico. Pero sin embargo,
si vivimos en Cataluña pagaríamos algo más.
En este caso hablaríamos de 22 puntos y medio
de impuesto sobre la renta ¿Por qué? Porque
en este caso, el tramo autonómico es un poquito
más alto. Y lo mismo ocurre en otras comunidades
autónomas como Extremadura donde pagaríamos
alrededor del 21 con 70 por ciento.
Y ahora me diréis ¡Pues esto es un sistema
muy parecido al de Liechtenstein! ¿Verdad?
¡Pues no tan rápido! Aunque haya un tramo
autonómico de impuestos, los gobiernos autonómicos
apenas tienen margen para cambiarlo. Es decir,
que el estado fija unos tipos y las comunidades
autónomas tienen un margen muy reducido para
subir o bajar su tramo ¡Pero no sólo eso!
Más de la mitad del dinero con el que se
financian las distintas comunidades no viene
de sus propios impuestos sino que viene, directamente
del estado. Son las llamadas transferencias
autonómicas que explicábamos mejor en este
otro vídeo.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en otros países
como Alemania, Suiza, o el propio Liechtenstein,
las regiones gastan lo que recaudan. Si tienen
muchos impuestos y la economía les va bien,
recaudan más o menos dinero. En España,
sin embargo, más de la mitad del dinero viene
del reparto que hace el Gobierno central.
Esto tiene una ventaja: si una comunidad quiebra,
el estado la rescata. Pero tiene una desventaja,
que apenas tienen libertad de actuación para
subir o bajar impuestos. ¡Y es más! La tendencia
es cada vez más centralista.
La armonización fiscal reabre las heridas
del Estado de las autonomías
En otras palabras, que España es mucho más
centralista de lo que creemos. Y ahora me
preguntaréis ¿Y todo esto… que tiene que
ver con la independencia de Cataluña? Pues
mucho. Porque antes de que estallara todo
este fervor independentista, lo que pedía
el Gobierno de Cataluña era que le dieran
más margen de actuación en los impuestos.
Es más, esta fue la chispa que encendió
todo. Concretamente el día en el que el,
por entonces presidente de Cataluña, Artus
Mas, se reunió con Rajoy ¿No me creéis?
¡Pues mirad esta noticia del año 2012!
Mas a Rajoy: “O aceptas el pacto fiscal
o te atienes a las consecuencias”
¡Exactamente! ¡Así es como empezó todo!
Pero ahora ya nos hemos olvidado de hablar
de impuestos. La pregunta sigue siendo ¿Tienen
derecho los Catalanes a votar en un referendum
si se quieren marchar de España o no? Y esto
es es lo que nos respondió el Príncipe Hans
Adam II.
Si tuvieras autodeterminación en Cataluña,
y pudieran marcharse de España, eso crearía
muchos problemas para Cataluña porque tendrías
un problema de minorías.
Digamos que hay una minoría que NO quiere
independencia. Eso crearía un montón de
problemas dentro de Cataluña. Porque dentro
de los nuevos estados tienes minorías que
no querían pertenecer a ese estado. Yo creo
que un sistema con autonomías a distintos
niveles quitaría casi todo el fervor independentista.
Pensadlo bien. En principio, parece justo
que si la mayoría de los catalanes quieren
tener su propio país, nadie se lo impida
¿Verdad? Pero imaginad este escenario. Imaginad
que hacemos el referéndum y el 60% de los
catalanes vota por la independencia. Sin embargo,
la mayoría de los barceloneses no quiere
formar parte de ese nuevo Estado Catalán.
Es más, a día de hoy ya hay algunos que
quieren crear su propia comunidad autónoma
que se llamaría TABARNIA. ¿Qué hacemos
en ese caso? ¿Qué legitimidad tendría el
nuevo gobierno catalán para obligar a los
barceloneses, o a los tabarneses, a estar
en un país en el que no quieren estar? ¿Y
cómo podemos resolver este problema?
Si aplicáramos la fórmula de Liechtenstein,
convocaríamos varios referéndums a la vez.
Uno por cada provincia, o por cada municipio.
Pero esto nos llevaría a otro problema. No
es lo mismo la ciudad de Barcelona, que tiene
más de 1 millón de habitantes, que GRAGEÑA
de las GARRIGAS, que sólo tiene 163. Es decir,
que el método Liechtenstein tampoco sería
una solución perfecta.
Si Cataluña se independizara, tendrías minorías
que estarían muy descontentas que querrían
que les permitieran quedarse en España.
Y aquí es cuando podemos hacer todo tipo
de propuestas. Podríamos dividir todo Cataluña
en distintos distritos electorales, podríamos
crear distintas subregiones. Podríamos hacer
mil cosas y nunca encontraríamos una solución
perfecta porque ESTO ES POLÍTICA (susurrado).
¿Os dais cuenta de lo que complicado que
es todo esto? No tiene ningún sentido reducirlo
todo a “estás a favor o en contra de la
independencia de Cataluña? ¿Estás a favor
o en contra del referendum? ¡No! Es mucho
más complicado que todo esto.
Y por eso, os dejo con esta pregunta ¿Creéis
que se podría importar el modelo de autodeterminación
de Liechtenstein a otros países? En casi
afirmativo ¿Cómo? Podéis dejarme vuestra
respuesta en los comentaros.
¡Pero esperad un momento! Porque como os
podéis imaginar, no nos hemos ido a Liechtenstein
solo para hacerle un par de preguntas al Príncipe.
Tenemos un documental entero donde os explicamos
todos los detalles del sistema político de
este país, que es único en el mundo. Y lo
vamos a publicar muy pronto así que estad
atentos a nuestras actualizaciones.
Y si esta es la primera vez que descubrís
este canal, recordad que sacamos vídeos nuevos
todas las semanas así que suscribíos y no
os perderéis ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Un abrazo y hasta pronto